at trouble for the airlines this morning
easyJet warning that the coronavirus
crisis could result and grounding the
majority of its fleet and IAG the owner
of British Airways says it'll be cutting
its capacity by 75% in April and me
let's get a bit of perspective on this
speaking to our business presenter Ian
King at morning Ian's I mean is this I
was talking about with our colleague
mark Kleiman about this last I mean is
this as much of a surprises as some
people suggest given you know the
dramatic drop in customer demand and the
the restrictions that governments are
putting on the industry well look as a
quoted company the likes of easyJet and
international airlines grew the owner of
British Airways and their Lingus have to
update the stock market as Regulus they
can when there is a material change in
trading circumstances and that's clearly
what has happened for bit I AG in the
case of them obviously over the weekend
Donald Trump extended the travel ban
from all European travelers to travelers
from the United Kingdom and the Irish
Republic as well and obviously that will
have an impact on IO G's trading with
easyJet likewise they've been forced to
make further capacity cuts and so you
would expect them to put out a stock
exchange statements we also heard
incidentally over the weekend Virgin
Atlantic calling for government support
for the aviation industry in our region
Neil this statement from easyJet because
there's one paragraph in it which really
does stand out and this is from easyJet
it says european aviation faces a
precarious future and there's no
guarantee that the European airlines
along with all the benefits it brings
for people the economy and business will
survive
what could be a long term travel freeze
and the risks of a slow recovery whether
it does or not will depend significantly
on European airlines maintaining access
to liquidity including that enabled by
governments across Europe in other words
they are looking for government to
support the aviation industry as I say
we heard similar comments over the
weekend from Virgin Atlantic and they're
not the only two who announcing further
grounding of the fleet's today air
france-klm which is I should say a in
terms of its finances a far more
precariously finance business than
either IAG or easyJet they've said
they're going to ground
90% of their
fleet we've also heard from finner
another major international european
carrier they're going to grin 90% of
their fleet
interestingly though cafe pacific over
the weekend have said they're going to
restore flights from london to Hong Kong
in response to demand from passengers
trying to get over to Hong Kong so it's
not all doom and gloom